>> Female Presenter: Hi.
My name is Jen Huang and I work in ads at
Google.
And I'm here to introduce Anthony, from Anthony's
Cookies.
So I'm very excited that you guys are all
here today.
So
just give a really short introduction.
Anthony was
attending San Francisco State University working
toward
an accounting degree when his friends jokingly
suggest he actually bake
cookies to make ends meet.
So he started baking cookies
out of his small student apartment which kick
started his ten
year career in baking.
And despite having no formal
culinary training, he opened his own bakery
and is now
the number one producer of gourmet cookies
in the Bay Area.
And his 'cookies and cream cookie' has also
been featured
as one of the Best Eats of San Francisco in
both 2010 and
2011.
Okay.
So give a warm round of applause for Anthony.
[Applause]
>> Anthony: Thank you.
First, I want to say -- I'm not going to
lie -- I hope you don't mind my just being
myself.
If I
stutter or trip on a cord or something like
that, just let me
do it.
And I got to say, I got to first thank Twitter.
And you're going to understand why.
That was the first
time I ever did something like this.
And if there was a
bucket to catch all the sweat, [chuckles]
it would have been very
full.
So that was -- I kind of broke the ice and
I kind
of get this.
It's not that bad speaking in front of many
people.
But did that about a month ago.
But I also want
to say thank you all for taking the time . Because
I know you
all work at Google.
I'm sure it's extremely busy.
It's an assumption but I'm
almost guaranteed for you to take your time
out of your
schedule and come see me or hear what I have
to say.
So
all right.
The first thing, I just want to let you
know, you know, a little bit about Anthony's
Cookies.
Jen pretty much told you how it all started.
And I'm
just going to kind of go into detail if you
don't mind.
So, first of all, I never in my life was good
at baking.
I know my mother, she was good at baking,
but the most
I ever came to baking was licking the spoon
after she got
done whipping whatever she made.
I never was good at
baking, wasn't inclined to baking.
And I want to make a
statement -- you're going to see how this
is connecting
later, but my -- I was always a.
I love mathematics.
I
love mathematics.
So I was inclined to doing things
towards accounting, even possibly engineering.
Architecture.
Things of that nature.
So that's how I
ended up at State.
You're probably thinking, accounting, math,
how in the world is
he doing cookies and good at it?
But, you know -- so I
end up at State and somebody suggested I make
some
cookies.
It wasn't anything to be taken serious, but
I'm
the type of person where, if it makes a little
bit of
sense sometimes, I just go ahead and run for
it and do
it.
So I ran and I did it and I made some cookies.
And
again, I wasn't, I wasn't planning on doing
this for
the rest of my life.
Or even turning it into a business
that it is now.
That was the farthest thing from mind.
It was something on the side just make a few
dollars here
and there, you know?
And I did it.
So a few dollars
started adding up.
[laughs] You know, nothing huge, nothing big.
But I started doing it.
And I just took an interest;
just got good at making cookies.
You know, so as time
went on, I learned I'm a little business savvy.
Natural
business savvy.
And I took my ability to make cookies
and I started marrying the two.
Using my natural
business sense.
And it's funny.
Like now, people tell
me, "Anthony, you're doing great marketing.
You're doing
this."
And I'm like I am?
[chuckles] And so, later on I'm like, "I
am."
Just doing things that naturally came to me.
So
for example, one of the things I would do
was -- because
as I'm making the cookies, I wanted people
to know,
"okay, look -- I'm the one making the cookies.
[chuckles] If you
want the cookies, I want to make sure you
can contact me.
You can distinguish me from anybody else.
You know?
So
it's the little things like putting -- I can't
come up
with the name.
I put a name attached a name to the
business.
Just most simplest thing that I thought.
Those are the things that I did.
You know from the
beginning.
Okay.
And so, years later, you know -- as
like I said.
And I have to say this.
And I'm sure many
of you can relate to this.
What has driven me and what
still continues to drive me is, I don't like
to
disappoint people.
You know, I really, I hate
disappointing people, you know?
And I don't like to
offer something that is not 100 percent if
not more.
So
if it was cookies, and like I said, forgive
me if I kind
of dance around a little bit.
But it was cookies in a
sense.
So I wanted to make sure when you got the
cookie,
you were blown away.
You were satisfied.
You know, so
having that as, you know, the batch up the
reason behind
what I did, that's how things always came
out better and
really good.
You know, and that was from the service
that I gave.
And that was also of course directly to the
cookies that I made, you know?
So all of that, you know,
years later, I ended up saying, "I got to
have my own
place."
I can't continue doing this the way that I
was
doing.
You know, so I went ahead and started putting
things together trying to figure out, "how
can I get my
own place to bake from where I can control
everything and
get more creative and offer a better service
and keep the
quality up?"
So I went ahead, did that, and so my mind
is working.
So I started reading books.
And if I jump a
little bit, forgive me, but that's why -- some
of the
people that I really admire are like Steve
Jobs, Jay-Z.
I'm like dang it.
Making cookies.
This is completely
different.
But really business and success and when you
have goals, it's very, very similar.
There's so many
similarities.
You know, so, and the reason why I
mention them, a lot of, many of them had humble
beginnings.
They just pretty much had a dream or they
had, they figured out they were good at something.
And
sometimes when you figure out you're good
at something,
you just start seeing what you're capable
of.
Or you
begin to see what you're capable of.
And where it can
possibly go.
And you just, there are walls and different
things in front of you.
But you just don't see.
You see
that's something you can overcome.
I had nothing at the
time of my idea of getting my own shop.
And I just
started reading books.
OK, "how can I raise the money?
How
can I do this?
How can I do that?"
So I started that.
I started, you know, asking different people.
I even
went as far as being told, "yes, I can do
this."
And
people back out on me.
And I was just never -- I was
always motivated, you know?
Nothing discouraged me.
So
eventually things happened.
And it was still rough.
It
was still very rough.
I ended up finally finding a
place.
Somebody told me to come look at this one.
I'm
like okay.
And I went and looked.
And it was a place on
Valencia.
That's where , that's the first shop.
The first one.
So okay.
And there's a friend of mine I was living
with at the
time.
He said, "you should go for this one."
"you
should go for this one."
"I trust you."
So I went for
it.
It was probably the, where we were, nothing
there.
Just
like the dead end of that street.
So, went ahead.
Took
dead end and started building it.
We opened up and it
was -- I was a new kid on the block.
I didn't have a big
name.
I didn't have any, you know, big chef that
I can
mention trained me or went to this culinary
school.
It
was nothing.
You know, except heart, passion, and I was
good at what I did.
And I'm confident.
Not arrogant
confident, but confident.
[laughter] Not arrogant confident.
So I
just -- I did it and we opened up.
I'm telling you
there's -- and I'm actually glad.
If you ever start
something or do something, I am asking you
take pictures.
Write notes, because you actually need to
see -- so a
year later you'll look back and say, "wow,
we've come
far."
But if you don't take pictures and do different
things like that, you can't really
see how far you've grown.
Somebody came in and took a
video of us.
And the place was bare.
Bare.
We were
unorganized.
We didn't know what we were doing.
All we
had was the cookies and they were good and
just passion.
So years later, you know, we just kept building,
kept
building, kept building.
Whatever came in, we kept
reinvesting.
Kept reinvesting.
And just kept, you know,
whether it's -- identifying a piece of equipment.
Different things that's going to make the
product more
consistent, you know, make a better product.
You know
make it easier on the staff.
We always reinvested
whatever could make it -- things more pleasant
for the
customers coming in.
We did that.
So that's how we
grew in that capacity.
This is after we finally got the place.
And I got
to say.
I think one of the main things about being
successful, you have Google -- huge.
You have so many Huge places out there.
I think just the main
thing that successful businesses focus on,
even down to
something as small as us, is never losing
sight of your
customers.
You know, never ever losing sight of your
You know, so it's funny.
Somebody mentioned
everybody that goes in there is so nice.
Employees so nice.
We're very strict on hiring process.
Because somebody
comes into your shop, you don't want to disappoint
them.
Not just with the product.
You want to make sure they're
pleased with how they're treated.
You know.
So and
again like the product itself.
It has to be 100 percent,
because you just don't want to disappoint
anybody.
Because why would anybody want to come back
to you?
So
those are some of the things that were at
the beginning
of Anthony's Cookies.
So now, we are -- right now I want
to go very well.
Constantly looking into growing.
And
hopefully I gave you a good foundation of
where Anthony's
Cookies came from.
And I want to, of course, share more
things with you but I really want to open
the floor.
Any
questions that you have for Anthony, the owner
of Anthony's Cookies, please ask it.
>>Female presenter: Please step forward to
the microphone
>> Female #1: Hi.
Thank you so much for coming.
>>Anthony: Thank-you
>>Female #1: I've been to your
place on Valencia many times.
And actually Jen was the
one who introduced me to it, to your place.
My
question is where do you get your recipes
and how do you
come up with it?
And you talk about making the product
better.
What's the process there of how you make the
product better?
>> Anthony: Okay.
Where I get the recipe -- the first place
I got
the recipe was -- I just read it off the back
of a box or
something one time.
[laughs] Because I was not serious about
this.
When I first started, I didn't have develop
a
business plan or anything like that, because
it wasn't to
me taken serious.
But as I started, you know, this is gonna
answer your question, then I
started paying attention to it.
So I took one basic
recipe and I just changed it as I understood
how the
baking process went.
You know, which is very
mathematical.
That's why I said earlier.
You see how it
ties in.
It's a science.
It's like my
cooking.
You know, you get to taste, change this, change
that.
But with baking, it's a science.
It's very
mathematical.
So the way I came up with the recipe, I
figured out one base recipe.
And then, from there, I
would just change it.
You know, I would just change
until I was completely satisfied.
I knew my end result.
And I would just change it until I
got the result that I desired.
You know, and I would
just listen to people.
Listen to people's criticisms.
I
would listen to people's, you know, if they
say this is
really good, I would stick with it.
If it's something
that they complained about, then I would change
it until
they were completely satisfied.
And then, as time went
on, I would just do different things and change
it.
Does
that make sense?
Yeah.
And one thing I got to say is,
when you're -- pretty at much anything -- but
when you're
making something every step you have to pay
strict
attention to it.
And that's the same thing with baking.
If you're making cakes, if you're making cookies,
every
single step, you can't take for granted.
You have to
put -- you have to pay strict attention to
it and make
sure it's done thoroughly.
Does that answer your
question?
All right.
Please, any other questions?
>> Female #2: Okay.
So I have two questions for you.
One is, what
is your favorite cookie?
And then the second one is do
you have any plans to expand your business
in terms of
maybe doing a cookbook or doing other types
of sweets
like cupcakes or cakes?
>> Anthony: Yes, yes.
There are definitely plans of expansion.
Right now, we don't plan on getting into different
types
of food.
We want to make sure we do one thing and do
it
well.
Do one thing and do it well.
And there are
definitely plans for expansion.
As far as a cookbook,
yes -- that's later though.
[laughter] Yes, we're going to get very
creative.
>> Male #1: Yeah, hi.
One thing I've always respected about
entrepreneurs, is you guys got to pretty much
navigate the
highs and lows all by yourself, right?
So I was wondering
sounds like I'm catching you on a high.
You seem
exuberant today.
But I was wondering if you could talk
about some of the low points you hit in your
business and
how you went about handling that.
>> Anthony: That's a really good question.
Definitely the first thing I
would say is attitude.
I try to make sure I have a
positive attitude.
And very optimistic.
You know, so --
and when we do reach a low or challenge or
difficulty, I
try to embrace it.
You know, at first, I would get a
little, you know, frazzled.
You know, a little nervous.
But now, it's more, usually if something goes
wrong or
something happens, you know, you embrace it
and learn
from it.
And just improve from it.
It may sound silly,
but that's really what you have to do.
You know, so I
would say some of the -- really hasn't been
major low
points.
I would say some of the biggest challenges
that
we've faced are -- I would say one of the
things that was
new to me is managing
like plumbers and different
professionals.
Whether general contractors or, you know,
different professionals like that.
It's a task managing
everybody, you know?
So I learned a lot from that.
And
the way I learned was I just paid attention
to what I
did.
I tried to make sure I didn't want make the
same
mistake twice.
And one of the things that I love.
I've
always done and I continue to do.
If I see somebody
strong where I'm weak, I'm very quick to ask
them
questions.
You know, whether it's a successful business
person, whether it's a book or, you know,
somebody that's
a successful business person that's around
me.
I pick
their brain.
You know, I develop relationships with the
right people.
Pick their brain.
Generally they give you
some very good pointers on how to deal with
your lows, you
know.
And ultimately I try to make sure I stay on
top of
things every single day so that you can prevent
as many
lows as possible.
And you know, and just when a low
comes up, you assess it and assess it.
Use all the
resources that you have and then overcome
it.
>> Male #2: I have a couple of questions.
Maybe you answered kind
of the first one.
So what was the hardest part of
starting a food related business in San Francisco,
because there's a lot of competition.
Is it finding
affordable places to rent?
Was it finding talent?
Was
it raising money?
Was it advertising?
And then I'm
going to ask the second question later.
>> Anthony: Yeah.
So I want to repeat that.
So what was the
hardest part of starting a business with food
in San
Francisco.
One of my benefits was I kind of didn't know
what I was walking into.
[laughter] You know, I guess I was a
little naive.
So, I didn't realize till later -- wow,
I'm in pretty much the mecca of food, you
know?
In San
Francisco.
You know, so it was pretty much what I do.
I
just did it.
Sometimes you have to -- whether it's a
food industry.
If it's technology.
There's so many different --
there's so much competition out there.
Sometimes you
just have to go for it, you know, and just
do what you
absolutely know is your best.
You know, do what you
And then, under no
circumstance, compromise.
You know, so in the food
industry, I just didn't compromise anything.
And you
know, the challenges -- with the food industry
-- it's
pretty much dealing with San Francisco -- the
health
department and building permits.
But again, it goes back
to embracing challenges.
I'm so glad they were hard on
us, because now, if you can open up in San
Francisco, if
you can open up a food establishment in San
Francisco and
be successful, you can pretty much be successful
anywhere.
Because it's so strict.
It's very strict.
You know, so San Francisco -- they're very
strict when it
comes to health.
You know, making sure you're following
the guidelines.
the guidelines of our sanitation.
You know, the building
permits.
And you would -- when you think about it,
it's
like, "oh, man, it's a headache going through
all this."
But then again, if you look at, "if this wasn't
done right,
this could cause a major disaster."
So you're actually kinda
glad they're on you very strict and you can
learn from it
to the point where now I can probably be a
general
contractor for any food--.
[chuckles] I'm glad I went through all of
that.
If you
ask me for food, people come to me regular
now.
How do
you do this?
How do you do that?
I can answer their
questions.
Does that answer your question?
>> Male #2: Kind of.
>> Anthony: Well, I want to make sure it's
fully.
[laughs]
>> Male #2: I just want to get any one of
those things stands out.
Was it really hard to find a place for instance
that was
affordable.
>> Anthony: It was hard.
That's hard.
Because I'm going to say
it like this.
It's easy to do anything, but if you have
standards, [laughs] that's where the difficulty
comes in.
You
know, if you want -- I can go pick a place
right now.
I
might be in the middle of nowhere.
[laughs] You know, so I can --
you can do anything you want, but if you have
standards.
I think the higher your standard is, that's
what really
dictates your level of difficulty.
So if I want a place
that is in a certain location, well, then
money is a
factor.
You have to factor that in.
You have to factor
in -- of course getting a little more expensive.
We open
up.
If you want to open up in -- then you have
to also
take into consideration will your concept
work here.
Just because it works here doesn't necessarily
mean it will work
there.
I mean, so you have to take all of those things
into consideration when you make a move as
far as finding
the right location.
>> Male #2: Yes, my second question was what's
your experience
advertising on Google?
>> Anthony: What's my -- ah -- ah, I see where
he's going.
>> Male #2: Jen invited me.
[laughter]
>>Anthony: Ah.
When you said the highs and lows -- and the
challenges.
[laughter] I wasn't expecting that.
But you got to
look into that.
But just so far as advertisement.
To be
honest, we haven't done any advertisement.
And that's
one thing people are like, "you have done
no
advertisement?"
It goes back to -- I guess a natural
business sense.
I make sure every single thing that goes
out has our logo on it.
You know, we emphasize word of
mouth.
And sometimes people make -- and I'm not trying
to interfere with nobody's marketing [laughter]
or advertisement.
So Google forgive me.
[laughs] But we just strongly treat
everything organic.
And it's not naive.
You know, if
you make a great -- I'm going to say this.
I like Jay-Z. [audience member whoops]
You'll see why I'm saying it.
Love Jay-Z's music.
Everybody I talk
to -- look what I'm doing now.
Because I like Jay-Z.
I
like his music.
I just mentioned Steve Jobs.
You know?
I can mention several people, you know?
If you like
something, people are going to talk about
it.
People
have fallen in love with our cookies.
They've fallen in
love with our cookies.
People have fallen in love with
our service.
And I mean, I'm not trying to be, you
know -- people, you know, they like me.
You know.
So
when they like you, they like your product,
they
naturally talk about it.
They naturally talk about it.
Right now, you have a cool little smile when
I say
something.
It was something there.
If I got to know
him, I might talk about him.
I'll talk about you.
[laughter] Sorry
to put you on the spot like that.
[laughter] But you talk about it.
So if you have that going for you, which is
I believe the
best thing, now what you do is make sure everything
that
goes out people are able to attach that product
with who
produced it.
And so, when you eat this cookie and you
open a box and it says Anthony's cookies -- oh,
you know?
We got to talk about that, Google.
All right.
>> Male #3: All right.
I'm going to be the last question..
>> Anthony: Yeah.
>> Male #3: Because I know everybody wants
cookies.
I've known
Anthony for almost 20 years and you guys have
seen the
calm side so I do have a question for you.
Let's see
some passion.
What has been the best moment in doing
Anthony's cookies.
Like, what has made this journey
worth it all?
>> Anthony: What has made this journey worth
it all.
You got to
come up with that one, huh?
[laughter] Because it's endless.
>>Male #3: This is the most passionate person.
This is the
mellow side.
You see this little animation but this is
the most passionate person I've ever come
across.
So I want
to see that passion come our right now.
Pick that thing that "wow, I never thought
I'd be here
doing this.
Or never thought I would have this."
>> Anthony: He just answered it.
He just answered it.
>>Male #3: Maybe this is it.
[laughter]
>> Anthony: I was -- there's so many.
It's.
I'll mention the
last thing.
It's so many.
And I think because of my
attitude, everything is just great.
Because just
being -- I'm like oh, I'm sitting here at
Google.
I'm standing at Google, it's
an honor.
It's an absolute honor that you all would
take
your time out.
That drives me.
That drives me to do
even more.
You know, just the passionate -- just seeing
where, I never in my life thought I would
be doing what
I'm doing and making these accomplishments
and continue
to make this continued success.
You know, so seeing
where I started and seeing where I am now,
that's an
ongoing great feeling.
You know, to passionate.
Just working, meeting so many different people,
you know,
and just not falling under challenges when
they come.
Not falling under challenges when they come.
And when
you're actually able to excel, I could talk
for days
about that.
You know, making people smile or when people
are pleased with you or they're -- they love
what you're
doing.
It's just a great feeling.
It's just a great
feeling.
So and that's pretty much.
So hopefully if
there was a little rough at the beginning,
forgive me.
Now it's funny after ten minutes later
you start, "ha, I wish that little ha would
come five
minutes into it."
I keep telling myself we're going to be all
right though.
But once again, thank you.
Thank you so much for taking
your time out.
Hopefully you enjoyed the presentation.
Take something from it.
And I know you'll enjoy these
cookies.
All right?
Thank you.
[Applause]